so good afternoon everybody and welcome
to the european commission's
press room today 14th of july
the college of commissioners held its
weekly meeting this morning and they
discussed the back
the package of proposals linked to
delivering on our commitments on the
european green deal president fonda lyon
will deliver the readout
of the college meeting she is
accompanied by the executive vice
president timmermans and the team of
commissioners
involved in this package president
the floor is yours yes thank you very
much and um
i'm let me start by saying that i'm very
happy
to be back in a busy press room to
present
this package so that's good to see all
of you and i'm delighted
to be joined by part of the team
who made this package possible and at
the very beginning many many
thanks and my respect to franz as the
first executive vice president who is
leading the green cluster
and to you the commissioners of what you
achieved
from janus to adina paolo
cadre rodriguez thank you very much this
was an enormous effort
but the result speaks for itself
um this group here does
represent not only the i think
outstanding knowledge
and the excellent teamwork within the
commission
but it also reflects the whole of
government approach
or the whole of society whole of economy
approach
and this was the message
almost exactly two years ago to the day
it was the 16th of july
when i put on the table my political
guidelines and
in there the core part was the european
green deal
the overarch arching goal was and of
course is
to make europe the very first climate
neutral continent in the world
and to build a new growth strategy to
get there
um i remember not everyone agreed at
that time and there were very
vivid debates but now two years on
we have come a long way we now have a
shared sense of purpose
we have a shared sense of direction we
know where we want to go
and what we need to do to get there we
know for example that our
current fossil fuel economy
has reached its limits and we know that
we have to move on to a new model
one that is powered by innovation that
has clean energy
that is moving towards a circular
economy
and this is why we set out to make the
climate
goal not only a political aspiration
but also a legal obligation and thanks
to our new
european climate law this is exactly
what we now have in place
two years ago we also set out our vision
about that transformation and today i'm
proud to say
that we have made good on our
commitments
europe is now the very first continent
that presents a comprehensive
architecture to meet our climate
ambitions
we have the goal but now we present the
road map to how we are going to get
there
our package aims to combine the
reduction of emissions
with measures to preserve nature
and to put jobs and social balance at
the heart of this transformation
and it also shows the value that this
transformation will generate
and how public and private investment
can and will of course
work together to make it a reality
we should always keep in mind roughly
one third of next generation eu
and the european budget will support
green projects sustainable projects all
over europe
this is more than 500 billion euros
at the european level alone then you
have to add the
national provisions in the national
budgets
and this all gives and we feel it
already we see it
certainty and incentives to the private
sector so that they complement that for
example through
investing in green bonds that are making
our
financial system more sustainable
so today it is about putting all of that
together in an
architecture that can drive us to where
we want to go
we have the goals we have the climate
law
we have it all underpinned by investment
and now today it's about the road map
it's a road roadmap to our new target of
at least
minus 55 of greenhouse gas emissions
till
2030. we chose
carbon pricing as a clear
guiding and market-based instrument
with a social compensation and the
principle
is simple emission of co2 must
have a price a price on co2 that
incentivizes consumer
producers and innovators to choose the
clean technologies to go towards the
clean and sustainable
products and we know that carbon pricing
works our existing emission trading
system has already helped significantly
to reduce emissions in industry and in
power generation
so we will strengthen the existing
system
in these sectors and we will make
emission trading system applicable to
aviation
and extend it to the maritime
we need this because we just have to
consider that
one single cruise ship cruise ship alone
uses as much co2 per day
like 80 000 cars and then we will build
a second ets
a second ets on buildings and road
transport
because we all know that buildings today
consume
40 of the energy consumption
and the road transport emissions have
continuously increased not decreased but
increased and we must reverse this trend
we must reverse this trend
and we must do it in a fair and in a
social way
and let me step back for a moment from
the
specific example if you look at
transformations
in europe every transformation we were
successful
when we combined market-driven measures
with the right
social balance and this is at the core
of our social market economy therefore
we call it a social market economy
and in this spirit the climate
transition will be accompanied by a
social climate
fund this fund will support
income and it will support investments
to tackle energy poverty and to cut
bills for vulnerable households and
small businesses
so this is real support for those
that need it most while the pricing is
effective and this is real solidarity
between member states and within member
states
we are presenting today um the
market-based tools and
tangible investment complemented and
underpinned
by a comprehensive regulatory framework
and i will ask my team in a moment to
present
the proposals to you but allow me a few
final thoughts
europe has always been the continent of
scientists
and innovators and we cannot always
compete with the sheer
size of our competitors or for example
the amount of natural resources they
have
but we can rely on the most precious
renewable resource in the world and this
is our ideas our ingenuity
our innovative power of our people
it is this spirit that should give us
the
confidence that this generational change
is not only realistic
but also optimistic we very often talk
about
taking our destiny in our own hands
this package this transition
is the true meaning of that the more
inclusive
the more successful it is today the more
we will have the freedom to act
tomorrow in the future
and over the next days you will hear a
lot more details
about the proposals and the percentages
the acronyms the allocation fees
that go with them these details do
matter but so does the bigger picture
change on this scale is never easy
even when it's necessary and for that
reason there are some
who will say we should go slower
we should go lower we should do less
but when it comes to climate change
doing less or doing nothing literally
means
changing everything the in fairness and
hurricanes we have seen over the last
few weeks
are only a very small window into what
our future could look
like but by acting now
when we still have the policy choices we
can do things another way
we can build for our future by design
and choose a better a healthier and a
more
prosperous way for the future i'm deeply
convinced that my team is deeply
convinced that this is our generational
task
and it must unite us it must encourage
us
because this is about securing the
well-being
not only of our generation but also of
our children
and of our grandchildren and i think
there is no greater
and no more noble task than that and
europe
is ready to lead the way now i would
like
to give the floor to the first executive
vice president franz timmermans who is
in charge
of the overall green cluster and the
european green deal thanks
thank you very much president and let me
start by thanking you
all my colleagues here president and the
ones who are not here and especially the
commission staff
for an incredible effort over the last
couple of months this is really epic
what our colleagues were able to offer
us in terms of quality in terms of depth
in terms of analysis so i believe we now
have a package
that can take us to our goal which is
now a legal
obligation of reducing our emissions
with at least 55 percent
by 2030 which would set us on a path of
climate neutrality
by 2050. as the president has said
um there is no time to waste people are
dying in northwest canada because it's
50 degrees celsius there northwest
canada
siberia reaches temperatures over 35
degrees
and central europe is over 40 degrees we
saw tornadoes in the czech republic who
would ever
have thought of that so anyone who wants
to
deny the urgency of the climate crisis
should look again
and we certainly don't have the luxury
of denying it and as the president said
sometimes people say whoa
take it easy not that much it's
difficult it's hard
yes it is difficult yes it is hard but
it's also an
obligation because if we would renounce
our obligation
to help humanity live within planetary
boundaries
we would fail not just ourselves
but we would fail our children and our
grandchildren
who in my view if we don't fix this
we'll be fighting wars
over water and food so that is
in my view the background of our efforts
but these efforts are very concrete
they have to do two things at the same
time
put a price on carbon and put a premium
on decarbonizing that is in fact what
we're doing
we're putting a price on carbon so that
people have the incentive
to use less carbon and we put a premium
on decarbonizing so that we stimulate
innovation adaptation we stimulate the
bringing to the market of new
technologies etc etc that will take us
to where we need uh to be you know there
is the
famous quote um in in hamlet
um time is out of joint or cursed spite
that ever i was born to set it right
that's it
time is out of joint because humanity no
longer lives within planetary boundaries
we were born to contribute to set it
right that is to
help humanity learn to live within
planetary boundaries
if we get to -55 in 2030 and
climate neutrality in 2050 humanity has
a fighting chance because the rest of
the world is watching us
is following us and is really looking
towards
us for the best examples to get us there
thank you president thank you very much
thanks now i would like to give the
floor to the catrice simpson
the commissioner for energy thank you
president and
thank you france for your leadership so
um reaching
the green deal goals will not be
possible without
reshaping our energy system this is uh
where the most of the
emissions are generated and very change
needs to happen first to make it
possible
elsewhere by 2050 most of our energy has
to come from renewable sources
as you know planning and building energy
infrastructure takes time
so to get to net zero by mid-century
we need an unprecedented transformation
during this
decade already the steady
renewables evolution in the recent years
and decades
must become a revolution and with our
proposal to revise
the renewable energy directive we are
making that possible
renewable electricity has by now become
the cheapest option
in many places and often it's european
companies
and european technology providing the
clean power
by pushing our 2030 renewables target
to 40 percent we are not only promoting
cleaner and cheaper energy production
we are also boosting an economic sector
with remarkable potential to create jobs
growth and trade with renewable energy
as a dashing but protagonist of the
green deal
energy efficiency is the unsung
hero without whom nothing would actually
happen
so everything we are presenting today
will become impossible
or at least very difficult if we do not
reduce the amount of energy we consume
being more efficient will immediately
cut our
emissions is the pressure
on the environment and reduce the need
for energy and other resources to
support our way of life
so energy efficiency not only enables
screen transition
it also makes us possible to
reach chest transition and increasing
our
efficiency allows us to slash energy
bills
and tackle energy poverty and this is
why we are proposing to upgrade
our energy efficiency directive change
of this scale is never easy
today's proposals will require serious
efforts from all member states and from
our businesses and societies
but being cleaner smarter and faster
also brings huge opportunities
um that we should be quick to grasp
thank you thank you for the economy
[Music]
yes i don't know if i should stay
so good afternoon thank you very
comfortable uh thank you president
the no okay we are very proud of the
leading role of the eu and i think
today we are confirming this leading
role
of course uh early movers have
advantages but also facing risks
and the risk here is what we call the
carbon leakage
so the fact that you have production
shifting towards countries where
standards are
lower or on the contrary
imports with higher content of emissions
entering in our markets for this reason
we are introducing this
carbon border adjustment mechanism we
are doing it
gradually with a
full compatibility with wto rules
we are putting the same price to
domestic production
and to imports
this will be a sort of premiere
at international level and this means
that
also we are ready to try to find a
balance between
our ambition and the necessity of global
cooperation because you need
ambition but also global cooperation
to have results from this point of view
cbam
as we call it is not a tax
it's an environmental measure but we
need also taxes
uh to influence positively
our behavior and this is why we are
reviewing our
energy taxation directive
it is 20 years old it is still
financing subsidizing
fossil fuels and we have to cancel
exemptions for fossil fuels and
change uh the method
of the energy taxation directive we will
not
uh has as base for taxation the volume
of fuels but their energy content
of course we will from have from this a
contribution
exactly to do what we are looking for to
put a price
to carbon emissions and to incentivize
positive evolutions thank you thank you
paulo
um now for the transport
thank you madam president
i'm putting forward three proposals for
transport
refuel aviation fuel umari time and
alternative
fuels infrastructure regulation all
present a ticket to economic growth
they will create a market for
sustainable alternative fuels and put in
place the right infrastructure to get
zero emission vehicles on our streets
and
in our seas and skies
i prepared a couple of figures for you
today
transport is today a source of 29
percent of the eu total ground
greenhouse gas emissions by 2050 we need
to cut
by 90 as we speak sustainable
alternative fuels
in aviation account for less than 1
0.1 percent of total eu jet fuel
consumption
and our goal is to go up to 5
in 2030. five percent might seem modest
but it means multiplying the quantity
used by
50 in less than 10 years
in shipping fossil fuels still account
for over 99
of the fuel mix by 2035 we want
13 reduction
in the greenhouse gas intensity of
energy used
on board ships road transport has the
advantage
that it started the carbonization
earlier but
20 percent of all greenhouse emissions
still come from our roads zero emission
cars and lorries
are already a reality but so is the lack
of infrastructure to recharge or refuel
them
we want charging capacity equivalent to
around 16.3
million points by 2050.
finally for hydrogen we need one
refueling station
every 150 kilometers along the 10th
network and in every urban node on the
tente
so these proposals will take us beyond
greening mobility
this is a chance to make the eu a lead
market for cutting-edge technologies
uh studies show that 92 of the
sustainable aviation fuels could be
produced in europe
for example creating more than two
hundred thousand jobs
in the renewable energy sector thank you
thank you very much adina now janusz for
the agriculture please
thank you madam president that's a
very important part of the package
adopted today is
forest strategy very important document
and forests play critical role
in many priorities of the green deal
and this very important forests are very
important for
climate adaptation and climate
mitigation
i think that the key word used in the
strategy is
multifunctionality this is very
important that
our approach is respecting the all
functions which our forests place that
it's very important to to mention
because there was a lot of concerns that
the forest strategy will be forestry
strategy will be first of all
uh forest protection yes this is very
important for the environment to protect
our forests to avoid the
process of deforestation of the european
union but
we respect all functions of of our
forest
the economic functions as a wood
industry
[Music]
forests are very important for this and
as a place of work
hundreds thousands of of workers and the
forestry sector and the
also the social aspects like the forests
can be the place of
tourism place of of rest for for
our citizens uh very important this link
with
uh between the forest strategy and
common agriculture policy adopted
finalized as a political agreement two
days two weeks ago
and we have instrument for improvement
of our managed forest management
in the common agricultural policy which
are eco schemes
we propose in the recommendation sent to
the member states that
agroforestry and joining the
the farming
and agricultural practices and forestry
practices is very important
and also carbon farming as a potential
eco schemes
we spent in the the current the last
financial period 6.7 billion
euro for uh forestry in
in budget that now the the idea
is to spend more and encouraging farmers
forestry owners for
improvement their practices and
first of all afforestation that's and
avoid the deforestation and the better
management of of our forest
thank you thank you very much and now
we're genius in cavities for
the environment fisheries and oceans
thank you very much and good afternoon
to to everyone let me
put a little bit more emphasis uh on
forests
and i'm very proud that today together
with the fit455 package
we have a forest strategy because
forests play a vital role
we're talking today about legislation
and important changes
but also we're not forgetting about
forests which are a huge
carbon sinks and also they host
a huge resources of biodiversity most
important
with our strategy that we aim at
protecting our old growth
and primary forests but also restore
those degradate degradated ecosystems
which due to increased pressure
all also due to climate change
unfortunately we are losing here in the
eu
but most importantly that we're building
in resilience
all the multifunctionality what my
colleague janusz mentioned
can be only maintained if our forests
are resilient
to climate change and future shocks and
therefore we will also roll out
a very positive and engaging initiative
of of
planting three billion trees around eu
not all trees planted can be called
forests and that's why we will go
a step ahead looking at specific areas
specific species which can be planted
and create the forest of the future
that we will do with of course enhance
cooperation
with our member state building on their
best practices
thank you thank you very much
college now the executive vice president
and the commissioners present on stage
will present you
the building blocks of these proposals
over the next two days so you will have
plenty of opportunities to ask questions
to them and the president will be
now available to uh to take a few
questions
so i will try to make a mixture of
questions
from the press room and from the
colleagues to many of them
almost 200 who are connected remotely so
um i will start in the order in which i
have them on the list with a question
from um ana galinek who is in the middle
thank you
i don't know if i remember how to use
this microphone in the press room
anymore
thank you for the question um a question
in german to the president if i may
um for president um
and the question to vice president first
vice president timmermans
if i may where do you suspect the
fiercest
resistance to your plans
i think frankly that what we present is
a holistic approach a package
that the package will get us to -55 in
2013.
now i'm sure that parts of the european
parliament and parts of the member
states
will not like elements in the package
but
we have tried to make a balanced package
if you don't like an element in the
package we can talk about that
but you can't dispute the goal which
still has to be
minus 55 because that is set in law so
if you
don't like part of the package come with
an alternative that could deliver the
same results
um we are open for that discussion we
will have to be of course and
you will see that member states and
parts of european parliament will
sort of criticize some parts of the
package but then
that's that's how it works in europe
then we start discussing and we find a
common solution so
i think at the end of the day people are
most
worried is this going to be fair i think
fairness
is a crucial point here fairness within
societies
and fairness between member states the
onus is on the commission
to prove that this leads to solidarity
and to fairness in this transition if we
can prove that
i think the resistance will be less if
we fail to prove that
then i think the resistance will be
massive
thank you very much we will now take a
question from a colleague connected
remotely and the floor goes to mates
schiffers
mates are you there
uh yes i'm here this is mathias havers
from hats finish here dark blood dutch
financial times i've got
two questions for mr timmermans
the first question is which of these
measures
that you announced today do you find the
most difficult to take
and the second question is do you as a
social democrat
think that a social fund of roughly 20
billion a year
will be enough to fight energy poverty
in the european union
i don't really have a preference for
which is more difficult all of them are
difficult
i mean nobody should have any illusion
that anything is easy here
we have to be honest it's difficult but
we need to do it
we need to do it and then on the climate
social fund
i think this is a wonderful instrument
because it could
not just help us avoid that vulnerable
people who are
at risk of getting into energy poverty
because of these measures
can be supported to avoid that we can
also tackle
more than that also existing issues of
energy poverty because the fund will be
big enough
to look at that as well so i am really
enthusiastic about this
if member states embrace the idea and if
we can get it
going i think this could lead to
a change of behavior both of those who
will be
affected which are the producers of
energy and it could help
the change of energy consumption also by
our citizens
with strong support from the european
union and the member states
thank you very much i will take another
question from a colleague connected from
distance canta are you still there
uh
[Music]
future
so what we do explicitly is
that we acknowledge that today it is
already
difficult for some people to pay their
energy bills or their mobility bills for
example to
drive and that we give
first of all an answer to that open
question
by first of all putting in place the
social climate fund
and it is tailored specifically
to address that question the social
climate fund will not only be direct
income support for small incomes but it
also will go
into investments in innovation
so that for example the market for
electric vehicles becomes broader
and as you know if the demand rises and
the supply rises
the prices tend to go down that is good
or for example that heating systems that
are modern
become more affordable and will be
installed in housing or
we have the strong renovation wave that
is financed by next generation eu so
this will be first of all in place we
have next generation eu
then overlapping the social climate fund
will come
and only then we start to build
the emission trading system the price on
carbon
for road transport and housing so that
we have always an answer for those who
cannot adopt who have a hard time to
adapt because of
a small income but overall we don't lose
the perspective for our common goal
to reduce carbon in the very end
carbon is damaging in a way our climate
and our environment
and those who suffer the most from that
are always those with the smallest
income so it's in our overall common
interest
to support those with the smallest
income but also to show them the way
as a society how we can improve the
situation of housing of mobility
while preserving our nature thank you
very much this concludes the college
readout i thank all the members of the
college present on stage but stay with
us because in a few minutes
executive vice president timmermans and
commissioner simpson will hold
a press conference to present one of the
building blocks of this package just
bear with us for a few minutes
to change the setting and stay tuned and
thank you
hello
you